what's up everyone we are back at the
blockchain for social justice conference
and we are now seeing dolls McKenzie
slaughter hello how are you thank you
for having coming on the show yeah no
problem get glad to be here today and
you are with beyond Capital Markets yes
and you co-founded that in general
partner that and you guys are doing a
bunch of different things
yeah I didn't talk about them all we are
doing a lot yes we're taking over very
ambitious yes yeah let's let's break it
down let's talk about it so I guess who
are you and how did you even get to this
place of your life
sure so McKenzie slaughter and how I got
here people ask me that and I just don't
know I like to say I'm half left brain
and half right brain so growing up I was
in my as a young adult I was always
concerned about having a career that
well you allowed me to be both creative
in analytical and so I kind of found
that world those worlds together
becoming getting into tech startups
getting into tech startups and getting
into text so I started coding at the age
of 18 and internship at NASA Langley so
I my bachelor's in yeah of course my
bachelor's in mathematics and computer
science I had my MBA in finance and my
professional background is working with
alternative investments working with
hedge funds and private equity funds but
from a creative aspect so from a
branding in research perspective so
first working with what like what I call
brain capital and helping private equity
funds portfolio companies do better
perform better and then with hedge funds
doing research due diligence making sure
that they're not fraudulent making sure
that they're doing what they say that
they're doing so that's kind of how I
got started and then when the financial
crisis started kind of happened all that
kind of like went away and I just picked
up a computer game and started coding so
I've been in fin tech since 2013 I have
launched a I've launched a my first
startup was a social trading platform
for women so teaching women about
how to invest in the stock market and
providing a platform where they can
actually buy and sell stocks and share
ideas trading ideas with each other so I
could go on and on want more I want more
yeah
so from there I met my great business
partner telly all new who's based in the
Caribbean and at that time I was looking
to create creative funds different funds
that can serve people a little bit
better since being in the FinTech space
and so initially I kind of relocated to
the Caribbean to focus on offshore
finance when I met my business partner
she had a partnership with the World
Bank and helping helping tech founders
and startups in that ecosystem in the
emerging markets across several islands
helping them grow and I kind of had to
change the heart then so from that point
on I kind of merged FinTech with with
social impact and what we call impact
innovation and helping them grow helping
to grow the ecosystem because the
Caribbean is very this ballot is
unbalanced right you have a lot of
wealthy people and then you have a lot
of the local people who are still
somewhat disenfranchised and poor so
I've been doing that for about four
years and during this doing these
accelerator programs that we did with
the World Bank we also built
relationships with the central banks
down there and so we have very good
relationships with the premier of the
st. kitts and nevis also the governor of
the central bank the eastern caribbean
central bank so and then somewhere along
the line is around 2015 we went to a
conference in Ireland for the money
conference which is which is hosted by
the people at Web Summit and that's why
I got formally introduced to Bitcoin and
blockchain and ripple and and all of
that and so we started working with got
a couple partners at that conference and
then we just started we've been building
products we've been kind of building
FinTech products on the blockchain since
2015 so now we're kind of at a place of
transition we've done all these
rado programs we've got a really good
deal flow we've got a good portfolio
solid portfolio FinTech and watching and
so now we kind of want to I want to go
back to my roots that it's alternative
investments and investing in people are
focusing on investors and investing in
the right people and bring the liquidity
to the people that we've helped in the
impact space in the impact startup space
and create a platform they're kind of
nurtures hedge funds hedge funds private
equity fund managers and even impact
fund managers though yeah Wow holy cow
from coding to NASA to building out
platforms for women to succeed better
and then to managing all these different
types of money across different
companies and florence and wow that's a
cool background thanks nice thing it's
not on purpose
yeah and then in a blockchain
introduction and in 2015 right yeah it
is a lot of work but it's true it pays
off tremendously it's so interesting the
more you persevere and keep pushing and
learning yeah growing more pays off yeah
keep expanding yourself okay so about
three years ago then you were introduced
to blockchain technology and then you
started to bringing boxing companies and
your portfolio fin tech companies in
portfolio and then you had a couple of
these like visions that you wanted to
manifest your partner right as well and
so it's all about these visions that you
want to manifest because they're really
ambitious but I sure I love them let's
hear them so I think the first one
starts with access to capital and access
to money in the Caribbean sending money
to tell your business my business
partner are having us and money to a
client or whatever out of the Caribbean
it takes the money gets lost and when he
gets just it just goes into the app it
just goes into the abyss of the internet
or whatever they're using it
and sending money out of the Caribbean
yeah and this is the case and this is
the case not just for businesses but for
people who you maybe from Senegal or
somewhere in Africa and work in London
or working in the US and you send money
back home it's very hard for them to do
that so historically they use Western
Union money ground and it costs a lot of
money it costs almost a hundred dollars
to send money just the fees are low it
cost up to $100 just to spend money so
there's a huge when you look at this
this what I guess the state of Finance
around the world and how people just
don't have access to or they can't move
their money or it's very hard for things
are they're unbanked it's very hard for
them to get a bank account and if they
do have a bank account then there are
limits of how much money they can keep
in their bank accounts where they go
open another bank account and all these
bank accounts have fees and so before
you know it you're just paying you're
paying all these banks you know you know
$50 a month in the fees and they're not
really helping people so that's kind of
where we started with our first
observation was so working with the
social manage third parties yeah that
are hindering our ability to send money
around the world who are families in
yeah pay for goods and services yeah you
know it okay so cool that's where you
started that's kind of where we started
and because my business partner telly is
has her own start-up Carter Isuzu apps
and it's rebuild she's really building
the whole financial infrastructure in
the Caribbean so money can move money
can move within within not within days
or months but within seconds right and
so that's what bitcoin is doing in
different crypto currencies that's well
we have our crypto wallets and it's in
doing that as well so we kind of started
there and we're working with a central
bank to do that to Eastern Caribbean
essentially to do that and isn't we're
not just focused on the Caribbean or
focus or the Africa as well it's it's
been it's very is even worse for them
one of our portfolio companies called
aggro plexi
is a startup agriculture /bin tech
startup in West Africa and they are they
support about 300,000 farmers well and
these are farmers that are cannot open
up a bank account and a bank and a local
bank because a local veins don't support
farmers small farmers so they're able to
open up a crypto wallet crypto account
managed to harvest in their equipment
wallet and actually sell their products
in Bitcoin and if they are in Yemen it's
just really amazing to see that to see
that happening so that is crazy cool
they're just leapfrog the banking they
just put it out we just cut it out
totally it's like we don't want to work
with us find we're just going to do this
Bitcoin thing so there's an exchange in
Nigeria that there's a centralized
exchange in Nigeria where they're able
to cash out so it's working for them and
it's the female farmers that really
adopted it so you know the adopted that
their earliest and the most so you know
and it's a lot safer
you know the naira is very inflated and
you're carrying around watts of cash you
know from selling your harvest it's not
safe no you know the farmers get get
robbed rate whatever but if it's all on
your mobile phone no no one knows you
have money or not so it's it's a big
movement I feel like the emerging
markets are adopting Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency a lot faster than and we
are here in the US in the US and even in
rural areas you know my family lives in
it's from Kentucky my dad's from a rural
area in Kentucky and I met a lady there
a grandma and just happened to be in the
library and she asked me how do i how do
I get into this like corn how do i how
do i buy a light coin because she saw
her son do it you know if so she wants
to do it she wants to do it for her
grandkids
she watched YouTube videos or so she's
over ready to go
we are real we re real global
a real global world right now so
information is really easy to get to so
you gotta teach us about more examples
like the female farmers in Nigeria that
are actually able to sell their crop
yeah just leapfrog the banking industry
completely it's just so interesting to
see the like couple of decades of
technology that the banks have tried to
build up to to make it so that you would
have to bank with them just be just
surpassed completely that's so
interesting yeah so give us some more
examples like that because I think
that's really yeah so there is one
example where I can't share that it was
too radical
nothing's too radical for our show
please McKenzie okay so another
portfolio company we have is based out
of Canada and Columbia and they came
into our accelerator program I see your
effect accelerator program people I okay
they're working with farmers again so
we're like okay fine farmers got the
most problems in the world so that's
five we can bring on another another
cohort this one in particular is focus
on the government gave this particular
founder area of Columbia that is and
he's been tasked with converting coca
farmers to cacao farmers so woah he
wants to use blockchain and
cryptocurrency to do that
so what he's basically dishes you Eagles
illegal right yeah whoa and in the
region that the government gave him it
back up into 2009 their currency was not
the Colombian face though it was coca
okay so this is the neighbor this is a
community that's basically deeply
enslaved by the cartel yeah by the
cartels so anti-government works with
the cartel to try to make them give them
a better livelihood and stuff so this
particular startup is called chuckle for
peace try chocolate but chuckle so he's
converting them and again it's a lot of
mostly in the
it's mostly female farmers that are
signing up and there they are
their farm now raises chocolate takes
three years yeah so hardest chocolate
say three years to harvest chocolate and
they make more money there's no one
hanging over their head asking for all
their money they were able to take some
home to feed their family they were able
to start a school create a school and
build a little economy for themselves
and they weren't able to do that
beforehand and so the farmers are also
the farming land is also geothermal so
they're able to mine rather crop is
being raised and so there's many
different types of things that they can
do with that land not just use Bitcoin
for harvesting but they can also trade
they can trade a mine Bitcoin while
they're waiting on their heart of this
it's just like the coolest it's the
coolest thing so it's really probably I
love it yeah the only thing that we're
recommending strongly recommending him
not to do is an ICO
because we don't want certain people
buying up his tokens and maybe pulling a
power-play and bringing those farmers
back into cocoa farmers so we don't yeah
so we're fighting him in other ways and
so that's kind of how the project that
we're doing beyond capital markets came
about with creating our own our own
crypto impact fund so I study him doing
her ICO which we have barred him to do
we don't want the cartel to buy into his
ICO just to be blunt we don't want that
so we're like okay we'll create a fund
for you where help invest and so that
kind of spearheaded what we're doing now
in creating this financial
infrastructure to support impact
investing it impact startups so so a
reason 200 million dollar fine
that is a crypto impact fund and we're
not going to be just investing in impact
project blotching for impact projects
we're going to be training in
and the new a new way for a new
generation of fund managers that will be
crypto fund managers and we will we want
our hope is is that they will have a
focus on impact projects impact projects
so that's one part of what we're doing
and that say is chuckhole for for choko
for peace they can now create their own
fund because they want to create a fund
or doing other things too but now they
can become a fund manager under us and
we give them the guidance and the tools
and the support to do that so there is
no there we've limited through his risk
of working with other people for
financial resources so okay so then the
the crypt of fund the two hundred
million dollar crypt of fund is also
what is not only funding the social
impact companies around the world but
also it is then able to help train them
through this program called beyond
Academy correct so we have an academy
we've kind of retired our accelerator
programs we did that for four years
we're very grateful for the experience
but we feel like there's a higher
calling now so we're helping people in
the impact space or people in general
who want to learn about crypto investing
so I've been doing these boot camps
since January
and I've been training all types of
people and they were also going to be we
have a program coming up that you can
meet anyone you can work at Red Lobster
or Walmart you can you don't have to
have about a MBA from Harvard Business
School to become a fund manager right so
if you want to become a stock broker on
Wall Street all you had to do was show
up you know back in the 80s and 90s so
we're taking that same concept we're
providing them with the training they go
through our program they pass
certification and training then we see
their fun will give them will give them
you know between will give them I don't
know what the number is I'm just gonna
throw out a number five to ten million
to see their seed throw five
and will be their mentors and we're
guide them and we'll help them
we'll help we're bringing to them dill
flow and research so they can make the
really good investment decisions so I
think that's what's missing in their
social impact space is that there aren't
enough people and that that looked like
us maybe it's Millennials or people who
think and believe like us that are on
the finance side so some of us don't
need to be technologists all of us don't
need to be on the technology side some
of us can be on the finance side or our
combination of both like I am so that's
really what my what our goal is with
that we've moved beyond Academy and to
beyond funds that's part of the reason
why I'm in the interlocutor space okay
because it's very unsaturated yeah and
we need people that are both empathic
and Polymathic that can sit here and
talk to people about whatever they're
building and the impact that it's having
on the world and be relatable and be fun
and engaging and make uninspired other
people through it and so when we have
everybody that is in the Millennial and
the gen Z age that is going into tech
tech tech tech tech we need a couple
people going into science and into
finance and economics design exactly all
these different types of fields that way
we can actually come to realize all of
our potential together as a team on the
planet so it then that kind of seems
like exactly what you've done
you took a what what is the combination
of the training set with Beyond Academy
and you've put it with people that have
a vision about a part of the world that
we don't really have right and so like
we don't know what goes on in koko de
cacao right we don't really know that
okay and we don't really know what goes
on with farmers that can't sell their
goods in Nigeria either we just we just
don't know these things that well they
know they damn well yeah and so if we
can empower them with the right tools
and the right
education especially about the future of
cryptocurrency and blockchain then they
can in a couple of months pick things up
and get rolling with them testing them
feeling them out getting better at them
investing into their area of the world
with this helping alleviate poverty in
those areas of the world
I'm loving it yeah tracking their data
you know tracking their impact data
I think blockchain has created this
enormous opportunity but we can actually
see so social impact is no longer a
sound bite it's measurable and we can
see exactly the impact and how much
impact is being created through these
social impact startups and projects so
that really wasn't has it been done
before there's been ratings but
real-time data they cannot be
manipulated because it's a it's on the
chain that that has that's going to help
social impact projects all over the
world Excel even faster because now it's
like okay I've shown my worth give me my
money you know give me my money I want
the funding you know so they can show
and prove themselves and in in a in a
stronger way and then you know VCS and
DC's they can't say no to that if they
do then there's something wrong with
them but you know it's going to be hard
for them to say no they're not so yeah
there's there's more here so you also
have the crypto exchange as well and
then the blockchain protocol can you
unpack these for us as well sure so
let's do the blockchain protocol and you
have a team of like a thousand people
working on oh I wish at the core is just
me and telly at the core of you know we
are we are you know very you know we're
doing everything and managing personal
lives at the same time travelling around
the world it's it's pretty crazy we do
have a small team of support staff so
we're kind of coming out of bootstrap of
is really important for us to bootstrap
in the beginning so there wouldn't be
anyone in an investor over our heads
controlling us
kind of limiting our growth so we can
kind of grow organically so now that we
know what we're doing now we're able to
take taken investment money investment
capital and it will really growth
capital at this point so the protocol
supports the the fund managers that are
coming through our program so as a
working through the program they were
used to beyond protocol or blockchain
protocol to help to help set up their
back office for their impact fund so
right now to create a fund right now
it's probably gonna cost you like a
million dollars right now you've got to
get compliance there's all these
regulations and and back-office
requirements and it's very expensive and
it's heavily relied on human capital
which you got to pay people right if you
put all that on the blockchain and use
technology then it cuts your costs down
to like like maybe tens of thousands of
dollars or maybe even under ten thousand
dollars to start a fund which is really
radical why does it cost a million to
ten thousand and how does your protocol
the neighborhood so you have to get a
custodian so when you're managing a fund
I mean like what the sec like a
custodian like to know like a bank
custodian a banker stuff a custodian
those are people that hold the money
just a bank they post the money in the
fund so if you heard like a venture
capital fund your dollars well that's
just one part of it so you had to have a
bank Estonian okay so typically to get a
traditional bank Estonian if you went to
you know if you went to JPMorgan if you
went to how many I don't have a bank
account of us anymore so I don't know
these big names set up with an overseas
account I know that's coming but
typically they want you to have a
retainer in this expensive right so
you're paying they want to you know they
want a retainer it's expensive it's
expensive to sign up for their their
services right there cause big custodial
services so that's number one is
expensive number two your your chief
your chief your compliance officer that
you're going to bring on
you know they want one $200,000 annual
salary maybe depending on level what are
they doing you what is the custodian
doing to earn retainers and these
salaries like they're holding the money
holding the money just while holding the
money
yeah insecurities no no oversees here
here it's how my traditional traditional
if you were fun you would go to a bank a
major bank taking work yeah say JPMorgan
you would say I want to you someone has
to hold your money when you when you
raise a fun yeah I create a fun you
can't have that money in your regular
business account you know why there's a
limit well there's a level of security
that's not there so you have to do
professional services professional bank
services that have that extra level of
security on the business account side
what's the security it's secure but in
terms of regulations and stuff it's not
the it's kind of its kind of required
for you to put that money in the
custodian sodium's okay yeah okay so
over a million no I'm just saying to
create a fund to create a plan to start
a fun yeah the operational backend it
can be a million but usually that's a
ten million fund that you would get a
custodian for all funds yeah but what's
a minimum I guess thresholds for to
raise a fund right to put it into like a
JPMorgan um I don't really know every
bank is different everything's fees are
different so it's like that's why it's
really hard and but that help that hurts
us right because if you've got a few
right but if you've got a seed stage
capital fund that maybe raise thirty
million dollars and they've got to cut a
million dollar check just to different
service providers supporting they're
fine correct and you know a fund manager
only takes two percent so two percent of
thirty million dollars is not that much
money so it's very hard it just doesn't
it doesn't make sense it doesn't make
the fun efficient and because they're
naughty for operating efficiently
they're not able to really help really
help to startups in the portfolio
companies that they're working with
so the first thing with the protocol
first thing to do is to reduce all
those back in fees from say like a
million dollars to like ten thousand ten
thousand dollars for example so that's
the number one thing so that way the
fund manager can breathe a little bit
and they can sit in that in not only
does it reduce cause they reduces the
time it takes to file paperwork and and
to make sure you're compliant with the
SEC and FINRA and all that is pretty
much automated on the blockchain so and
you're using smart contracts with that
so it's just a lot easier everything is
properly documented you only have the
document at once you don't have to put
it in a in a form you know you don't the
create a word dot and then transfer that
word dot to the SCC form or you know
it's just it's just one seamless process
and that's not happening right now and
so that's a very useful protocol yeah so
there's all the protocols out there like
that but ours is focused on impact so
that's the first part of the protocol
the second part of the protocol is that
it focuses on measuring the data for
their portfolio companies or forleo
companies so there's a partner I forgot
it on boards the investors as well so in
a fund you have an LPS those are your
high networks or family offices even
your pension funds your insurance
companies they invest in venture capital
and private equity funds even hedge
funds so you can on board them easier
and it cuts down the time it takes to
transfer their investment into the fun
using watch-chain technology so I hope
he can join a fund faster right and with
less paperwork it's more effectively
right is this more effective and then
they get the ultimate transparency right
so they get to see what's going on in a
fine right because everything is
everything is accessible right all the
data is accessible so there's less fraud
there's less
scamming going on with hedge funds or
private equity funds you know and LPS
don't lose their money they can see
what's going on in real time
that's very important it's not happening
right now that's how you get Bernie
Madoff
so no Bernie Madoff what's going on it's
right in the real-time money bank with
transparency of the blockchain right
interesting so previously couldn't
Madoff did is he he he was very
well-connected mm-hmm in New York and
around the world and it was all based on
relationships he had nothing to show but
false false false statements you know
that can you know that cannot happen on
watching right you can't create two two
set of statements one for the SEC and
one for the investor which is what
Bernie was doing that all that goes away
right so there's trust built trust back
into the financial system so yeah yeah I
love that trust and financial system
things you don't usually hear together
right that's great yeah so that's a
that's a really big thing so you're
building the protocol with just two how
many people are building that out we're
gonna create a team for that so I'm not
going that by myself and it's not a
crazy
it's not a lot chamber to call from
scratch and more likely it'll be a cross
chain of a couple of stellar and a
couple of other ones that we really like
and then what about the cryptic exchange
do we touch on that no so the exchange
so after the fund managers have their
funds have created their funds they can
tokenize it and they can trade it on the
exchange and that's the trend that's
happening right now so this would be
like if the if the woman farmer in
Nigeria was to then become part of the
beyond Academy and then get trained to
manage a crypto fund and then was to
invest into companies in Nigeria and
then those companies would be managed on
the crypto exchange
therefore right yeah those companies can
actually list on the exchange but the
the female farmers fine can actually be
tokenizing listed on exchanges as well
cool
now I see kind of how it all goes
together now the ecosystem sense when
you first listed off all these things
and I was writing them down I was like
how does it perfume and being do all of
this stuff and then now that we've went
through it and we broke it down and I
seen the different pieces and it makes a
little more sense now I'm like okay well
there's a lot of interplay going on
exactly yeah yeah yeah it's a process
right so it's not like one over here one
product over here my product over there
it all tells a one story so it's very
cohesive though so we talked a lot about
social justice and about blockchain that
was fantastic to the central pieces to
why we're here today right yeah and I
love what you're doing I want to push
some marbles a little bit a little bit
of time marbles here away I got that I
don't want to make some connections dude
that'd be great things come to fruition
there now we want to ask you a couple
questions that we asked on the show
quick ones the first question is what do
you think about the exacerbation of
wealth and equality due to exponential
technology okay so you're talking about
to walk accumulation with technology
right a tech space wealth accumulation
specifically being exacerbated by
exponential technology and then also how
the bottom is much slowly slower at
increasing its wealth than the top is
exploding yeah yeah so what's what do
you think's going on yeah it's kind of
going back like the rich are getting
richer and the poor are getting poorer
and it's like the rich are getting rich
which richer and the poor getting richer
like barely barely yeah yeah well to me
that's poor yeah I mean it's it's a
problem so you know back in November
December of last year there was a big
sell-off a Bitcoin around the world and
now you have these crypto billionaires
because they sold their Bitcoin that
they bought for five cents back in 2011
2009 2011 wherever you know and so you
have that part coming in I can talk all
day about this other observe some things
that are really creepy can you tell us
all about the things he
I think that because of the wealth
accumulation new wealth accumulation
within Krypton I'm just going to talk
about that part what we've had so a lot
all right it's a lot but what we've seen
is a resurgence of colonialism which is
really really scary which is really
scary and there's some hospice
colonialism and expats I'll give you an
example where we go for example so you
had to hurricane and their
infrastructure is just really dismal and
so you had a lot of crypto people moving
to Puerto Rico and in and they weren't
really about helping they were about tax
savings well they were about tech
savings and another buying a lot in the
land and how can you go in and buy the
children's museum
that was a Children's Museum isn't it's
no longer they don't even have a
children use them anymore in Puerto Rico
so it's like well wait a minute you
first have to give back yes the
Caribbean is known for a luxurious you
know living for the wealthy and stuff
like that you could hide your money
there pay less taxes or whatever you got
to give back to the people at at some
point so that mindset wasn't there in
Puerto Rico and the whole big Puerto
Rico move movement happened earlier this
year that wasn't that wasn't even
thought about you know see how you still
have these Puerto Ricans they don't have
water and electricity and they're dying
they're still dying because they don't
have basic necessities and this is still
happening and meanwhile you have all
these rich people coming in rich crypto
people coming in and and creating their
own and creating our own ecosystem on
top of these people dying and hurting
from the hurricane and so that you know
that is not that does that makes us look
that as in it in the blockchain crypto
community that makes us look really
really really bad and so we got to be
sensitive and mindful of that of course
you want to go somewhere else
taxes here are outrages the you know the
fact that you had to pay taxes on a
commodity you know it's it doesn't even
make sense we know that that the SEC and
the CFTC we know they don't know what
they're doing
and you can't come to the Caribbean I'm
sure Switzerland Ireland wherever but
just be mindful of the local people
there that are there because there
historically had been hurting for a long
time right
even before America came here or from
America was created that we know of you
know they've been hurting for a long
time so that insensitivity has really
pissed off a lot of people in the
ecosystem and it has really embarrassed
us you know it's been an embarrassment
so Wow first example alright give us the
others but the other part I see on it
just like the example with the farmers
the farmers in West Africa what I'm
seeing right now I guess because I live
in America in the Caribbean as well and
travel around the world as I'm seeing
that the emerging markets in the
developed country who are mainly America
we're kind of starting to switch places
and if we don't pay attention to human
issues in America we're going to end up
like Nigeria in India we're going to be
the emerging market if we don't pay
attention and if we don't bring in that
human aspect to politics in finance and
stuff so we're going to lose it so you
know we're like the Romans right now so
it's you know if we fall we're going to
fall hard and and you see have all these
people trying not to make that happen
but at the same time you have a lot of
tone death wealthy people who are just
just don't they just don't it's not that
they don't care it's just not in their
space they don't have to deal with it on
a day-to-day basis so they don't know
about it right so I don't know how you
can reach those people because they're
completely isolated so you think that
potentially the technologies that are
being built that are going into the
hands of the developing world could
leapfrog them so much to where we are
how we educate people here is not going
to keep up to how they've grabbed onto
the technology and ran is it I mean
think about it if you're if your country
has been poor I mean
so years hundreds of Union if you've
been living with a Walmart and a
delivery store everybody's chilling on
Netflix exactly yeah yeah that's a
pretty good way to put it and it's funny
cuz like my business partner she just
swimming from the Caribbean on Thursday
and I'm from Los Angeles so I showed her
around Los Angeles a little bit and
she's like this is her saying she's like
why I asked y'all coming down to our
Islands and our lands emerging markets
and you can't even take care of your own
homeless people in your backyard and I'm
like you know what you have a really
good point why are all these social
impact people running off to Africa to
help the poor people there we have we
have extremely poor people here in the
US there we go yeah and we're not
helping though we're just turning a
blind eye and we're building technology
that's come that's that's extinct ting
their jobs right so we're creating more
homeless people here and the technology
that we're building we want to push it
off to the other to the other developing
countries they get it first before we
give it to our own people here and like
rural America or in the south or
anywhere yes seriously that's the
problem what's the problem that's some
real serious [ __ ] that's yeah it's
really crazy
yeah so if you look at the whole
holistic you know story holistically
it's like it's really scary it's really
really scary as seems as though as we
globalize we also need to be very aware
of our community yes at the same time so
Justin I mean we literally live on a
street that has techies that walk next
to homeless people yeah yeah so so it's
kind of it's it's kind of really strange
yeah okay that was a very interesting do
you have another point on that topic
give us another row please I love the
technology the technology that's being
created by the upper echelon or the 1%
and whatever you want to call them of
tech and wealth I think they're coding
with with with colonialism in mind
the colonization in my digital
colonization in mind I don't think it's
working but I think that they are doing
that with with with that in mind whether
they're doing it on purpose or not you
have a lot of people who think that
colonization or colonialism is a way of
life that works you have a lot of people
that are just Pro not doesn't mean that
they're evil or anything like that they
just see it as a system or an
institution that has been working so if
it ain't broke don't fix it
doesn't mean there are horrible people
it's just there it's just
institutionally been institutionalized
that way what do you think then is the
mindset of the 1% that are coding for
the future it is our most is the mindset
to retain the 1% as continuation yeah I
think they're coding with with that in
mind ok let me keep what's mine they're
coding for a bifurcation of
socioeconomics down yeah yeah they want
to keep it the way that it is I'm not
I'm not gonna this is this is this is
the first time that I'm saying it on the
show yeah but it's been something I've
been thinking about a lot as well yeah
because I have been thinking about it a
tremendous amount I haven't made a
public opinion about it and but I think
that it's a possibility yeah the fact
that it's a possibility should be
vocalized because not everybody is a
benevolent and benign human some people
are just pure capitalist and greedy and
don't and don't care and there's a lot
of people in that 1% tech wealth world
that are just like that you know they're
like that they just about the money
maybe we can't keep doing that or we're
going to really be we're going to we're
going to cross that point of no return
as as a country here in America so yeah
yeah the feminine energy is actually
really important to make sure that like
the macho mama Gaia this whole vibe ya
can like stick tight and stick to yeah
it's our saving grace and so would you
ok but I'm talking about America
specifically may have some adjustments
and if they do we don't make those
adjustments we were all suffer to take
take this into account as we come to an
end
is playing off your last point think
about the who is at the forefront of the
best robotics yeah who's at the
forefront of the best artificial
intelligence systems in the best
weaponry right and those things mix
together but that's what's half the poor
in the middle class stand no chance
against that because it's not even human
anymore now it's robot AI gun so what
was the one that what was it Alexis with
you some testing on Alexis was I think
it was Alexis there's some testing and
then it being like really racist on
Twitter oh that was Microsoft I was in
Microsoft it was raised that's because
out of all the comments the machine
learning algorithms picked up hate
speech right it was it's a joke it picks
up hates right but where were they
learning from from humans exactly right
yeah so so if you unleash an AI that
just learns it's going to learn [ __ ] as
well as much how many nice comments are
there on YouTube how many nice comments
are there on Twitter
you